like i said you know this is very weird
she said so what if it's weird
dynasty star catherine oxenburg on the
hbo docu-series the vow
now she says her daughter was
brainwashed by a cult run by keith
renery
and today ranieri was sentenced
you think that you always have your mind
but the fact was that mine was hijacked
i was the first woman in my group of
slaves to be branded
catherine oxenburg's daughter india who
was branded with the sex cult leader's
initials
told the sentencing judge today that
keith renery deserved
life in prison if he was released you
would hurt more people
and this afternoon her wish came true
india was part of what prosecutors
called a
master slave sisterhood that rani kept
in line with blackmail
the cult also name-dropped hollywood
stars to recruit members
they said they had people like gerard
butler jennifer aniston
take the courses just a really good
season too
smallville actress allison mack was a
major player
she pled guilty last year to charges
related to manipulating women
including india into becoming sex slaves
for renieri
so how did india break free my daughter
is not in her right mind
her famous mother catherine who shot to
fame on dynasty in the mid-80s
leveraged her celebrity to grab the
attention of the media
and prosecutors she fought like hell and
she didn't stop
i mean you're gonna make me cry we were
on set for one of catherine's most
famous scenes
this pool fight with heather locklear
i'm hoping we can do it in one take
but for india catherine's latest
real-life role is her greatest
their mother-daughter journey is at the
heart of two major documentaries
this organization would still be going
on if she hadn't exposed it in the media
in my opinion